what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if this
is your first time here my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about all things data data science
statistics and programming subscribe for
all kinds of content just like this and
hit the notification bell so YouTube
notifies you whenever I upload a video
this is my statistics tutorial series
where I give you all the applied
statistics knowledge that you need to
conquer the data science world in my
last video in the statistics tutorial
series I outlined the hypothesis testing
framework and the various steps that go
into these problems you start by
defining a null and alternative
hypothesis as well as picking a
significance level then you calculate a
test statistic which basically
summarizes how extreme your data is
you'll use the distribution of that test
statistic to calculate a p-value and
then you compare that p-value to your
significance level if the p-value is
lower than your significance level you
reject the null hypothesis if the
p-value is higher than the significance
level you will fail to reject the null
hypothesis we need to talk a little bit
more about what a p-value actually is
because it's one of the absolute most
important definitions in all of
statistics and it's also one of the most
misunderstood and misused so we're going
to go through the definition of what a
p-value is but perhaps more importantly
we're gonna step through what a p-value
is not the definition of the p-value of
a test is the p-value is the probability
that we observe a test statistic as
extreme or more extreme than we did
assuming the null hypothesis is true now
I have a variety of other things which a
p-value is not and these are some of the
most common misconceptions of p-values
so a p-value is not the probability we
observe a test statistic as or more
extreme than we did leaving out that
whole part about the null hypothesis
being true a p-value is not the
probability that the null hypothesis is
true a p-value is not proof of anything
and a p-value is not indication of
effect size or effect man
nough tude let's start with this first
misconception about p-values which is
that p-values are the probability we
observe a test statistic as extreme or
more extreme than we did so we're on the
right track but we forget about the
whole part about the null hypothesis
being true now this is a fairly common
thing that people who are just learning
statistics for the first time can tend
to forget let's use the example from my
previous video where we pretended to do
a sample of 50 people and we found that
the average amount of time people spend
on their phones in America daily is 3.2
hours from our sample now that number
three point two hours was used to
calculate a test statistic but in and of
itself
what exactly does taking that sample and
finding a mean of 3.2 hours really tell
us without any prior belief or prior
information like that we expect the
population mean average hours to be 3.5
hours the three point two hours number
doesn't really mean anything and there's
no real way for us to use that in a
probability calculation it's that
initial assumption that we started with
that the population mean is 3.5 hours
that gives that 3.2 hours some kind of
context as well as a basis for us
determining whether it's extreme or
whether it's something that's expected
so don't forget about that clause about
the null hypothesis being true because
it's really that part that gives your
entire hypothesis testing problem it's
required context I personally really
like writing the definition of a p-value
out as a conditional probability so like
as the probability you observe a test
statistic as are more extreme than you
did given the null hypothesis is true
moving on to a second common
misconception that people can have about
p-values some people will mistake the
p-value as the probability that the null
hypothesis is true and this is another
one that comes up a lot with
introductory statistics students just as
a disclaimer the overwhelming majority
of the time when people begin to learn
statistics or even
they think about these concepts like
hypothesis testing and P values in real
apply data science work they are
thinking through what's called
frequentist statistics which is separate
from what's called Bayesian statistics
these rules are a little bit different
under that context but under a
frequentist framework the probability
the null hypothesis is true is either 1
or 0 because we don't actually know it
but the null hypothesis is either true
or its false meaning your probability is
1 or 0 the p-value that you calculate is
a probability related to the data you
collected from your sample and how that
relates to the null hypothesis but the
p-value is not a statement about the
null hypothesis itself
now the third misconception of p-values
and this is possibly the most egregious
of all of them is thinking that a
p-value proves anything so before we get
into this we're gonna look at this super
popular xkcd comic and it's going to
illustrate an idea called p hacking now
this is typically when you perform a
whole bunch of statistical tests in hope
that that one is gonna come out which is
going to return a statistically
significant p-value so to start off here
we've got some scientists working on
some really important things playing
Minecraft yadda yadda yadda you know the
drill and they start by finding that
based on a p-value of 0.05 that
jellybeans are not linked with acne at
least in the aggregate so then
investigators look at 10 different
colors of jellybeans they test all of
them and they find there's no link
between them and acne at the point 0 5
level then they do 10 more tests using
different colors and they still find
that there's no link between any of
those colored jellybeans and acne but
then lo and behold they run one more
test and then they find that green
jellybeans are significantly linked to
acne at the point 0 5 level so a great
day for the scientists they can publish
their findings and then go back to
playing minecraft I guess here's the
thing if the null hypothesis is true and
we treat the p-value just like it's a
random
variable it actually follows a uniform 0
1 distribution meaning yes there is a 5%
chance that by chance alone you will
find a p-value that is less than point
zero 5 so there's really a couple points
here on one hand even if the null
hypothesis is true we have a 5% chance
of rejecting it even when we shouldn't
if we're picking a 5% significance level
that is of course making a type 1 error
but it also goes to show you how
arbitrary the point 0 5 cutoff point is
and remember point 0 5 is selected as a
significance level out of convention and
because it's a nice clean number there's
absolutely nothing magic about it
another important point here is that
p-values are really only as meaningful
as the setup that you did for your test
and to illustrate this let's just use a
really silly example and keep in mind
with this that the absolute most
important assumption with a t-test is
that you have a random sample that's
truly representative of the population
that you want to learn about in my
example about how much all Americans use
their phones on average on a daily basis
I started with a null hypothesis of MU
equals 3.5 against an alternative that
mu was smaller than 3.5 but I could have
very easily over sampled elderly
Americans who probably don't use their
phones very much and I almost definitely
would have come back with X bar much
smaller than 3.5 so I would have gotten
a very extreme test statistic and
probably a very very low p-value well I
do have a really low p-value but it's
because I don't have a random and
representative sample so the set up for
my study is terrible and that p-value is
meaningless now this is obviously a
really extreme example but this general
principle should be in the back of your
mind whenever you're interpreting a
p-value as it relates to something
that's practically significant this
brings us to misconception number four
which is that p-values are indicative of
effect size or effect important
and the key here is that there is a big
difference between practical
significance and statistical
significance and this is probably
easiest to see in the case of having
massive sample sizes let's say that we
take a sample of size 500,000 and again
our null hypothesis is that the average
number of hours Americans spend on their
phones every day is 3.5 hours then we
record our sample mean and our sample
standard deviation at three point four
nine hours and one point two hours
respectively plug these numbers into our
trusty calculator that is R and we end
up with a test statistic of T equals
negative five point eight nine three and
a p-value of one point nine oh two times
10 to the negative ninth so an insanely
small p-value over an effect size that
practically speaking anyway is
completely and utterly meaningless it's
for this reason that lots of people and
throw me into this boat ii don't like
hypothesis testing as much as estimation
procedures like confidence intervals on
one hand the null hypothesis is always
going to be at least a tiny bit wrong
even if you have this kind of tiny
effect size that isn't meaningful in any
kind of practical sense but we're sort
of glossing over the information about
magnitude and effect size because we're
boiling everything down to this binary
significant versus not significant
decision when alternatively you do gain
more information by providing confidence
intervals because those provide windows
of plausible values that that thing that
we're trying to learn about could live
inside at the end of the day it does
come down to your audience because some
people do truly intuitively understand
p-values and doing hypothesis testing
can prevent serious unnecessary
information overload however you do need
to know your audience and sadly p-values
are very commonly misunderstood and they
are knowingly and unknowingly misused
especially by people who happen to have
a stake in the outcome so please use
p-values and interpret them accurately
and responsibly
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it and you'd like to support my
work the best thing that you could do
for me would be to share this video
otherwise leave a comment down below and
let me know the worst example you've
seen of p-values being misused and then
also consider smashing the like button
too then I'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then Richard on
data